جانبه قال مسؤول دفاعي امريكي للجزيره
انما وصفه بمزاعم الحوثيين بشان استهداف
السفينه الامريكيه اوشن جاز لا اساس لها
من الصحه ومن جهه اخرى قالت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه البنتاجون ان القوات الامريكيه
في موقع الفرات للدعم في سوريا تعرضت
اليوم لهجوم بعده صواريخ دون وقوع اصابات
او اضرار واضاف البنتاجون ان هجوما اخر
وقع بصاروخ واحد على مهبط الطائرات بميلان
من ناحيه اخرى ودائما وفق البنتاجون فقد
تعرضت القوات الامريكيه في قاعده عين
الاسد بالعراق لهجوم بمسيره ولم يخلف
الهجوم اي اصابات او اضرار ماديه ومنذ
الساب عشر من اكتوبر حتى اليوم سجل اكثر
من 150 هجوما على القوات الامريكيه في
العراق
وسوريا فادي منصور مراسل الجزيره انضم
الينا من البنتاجون فادي اولا ايه تعليق
سريع ماذا تقرا ب مسارعه المسؤول الامريكي
بنفي تعرض سفينه شحن امريكيه من قبل
الحوثيين لصاروخ
نعم نحن في ضوء اعلان العميد يحيى سريع
المتحدث العسكري باسم انصار الله الحوثيين
حول استهداف هذه السفينه اوشن جاز خصوصا
انها ليست سفينه عسكريه هي سفينه شحن
مدنيه ولكن من المعروف ان قياده المواصلات
في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه تتعاقد في كثير
من الاحيان مع سفن شحن المدنيه لنقل
العتاد الثقيل تواصلنا مع هذا المسؤول
الدفاعي وبعد التحري من قبال قال ليس هناك
اي معطيات استخباريه تدعم هذا الزعم من
قبل الحوثيين وبالتالي نفى ان تكون هناك
اي هجوم في تلك المنطقه او على سفينه تدعى
اوشن جاز فادي بخصوص الهجمات الاخرى ما
التقييم الامريكي لهذه الهجمات الاخيره
وخاصه بان وتيرات
تتصاعد في الايام
الماضيه نعم جلال ليس فقط الوتيره ولكن
ايضا النوعيه يوم السبت كان هناك هجوم
كبير كما اشارت نائبه المتحدث باسم
البنتاغون صبرينا سينغ بوابل من الصواريخ
بينها صواريخ بالستيه سقطت على قاعده عين
الاسد الجويه في غرب العراق وادت الى
اصابه جنديين امريكيين باصابات دماغيه
رديه وايضا اضرار في منشات تابعه للقاعده
اعتبرت ان هذا الهجوم فريد من نوعه الوابل
كان كبير وتمكن بحكم ال من تصفهم
بالميليشيات المدعومه من ايران من اختراق
الدفاعات بحكم العدد الكبير من الصواريخ
التي سقطت لكن كان لافتا رغم ذلك رغم
الحديث عن اكثر من 151 هجوما في سوريا
والعراق وهذا الهجوم تحديدا يوم السبت على
قاعده عين الاسد ان المتحدثه اعتبرت ان
هذا الامر لا ينظر اليه البنتاغون على انه
يمثل تصعيد اضافي وانها ليس المره الاولى
التي تستخدم فيها الميليشيات المدعومه من
ايران وفق تعبيرها هذه الاسلحه وان اشارت
ان البنتاغون يعتقد ان هذه الاسلحه توفرها
ايران واصرت على ان الولايات المتحده لا
تريد ان يتفاقم الصراع في غزه ولا تريد ان
عمليا تنخرط في حرب في المنطقه فادي منصور
في البنتاغون شكرا لك